CAN DO IT TO YOU.
IN A CAMPAIGN LAST YEAR LIBERALS
ACROSS AMERICA GOT PLASTIC
STRAWS BANNED IN MANY CITIES AND
RESTRICTED AND AN ENTIRE STATE.
LIFE GOT WORSE FROM NORMAL
PEOPLE BUT NOT BAD ENOUGH.
NOW LIBERALS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
A NEW TARGET, AT SOME THING
THERE IS TOO MUCH OF LIKE HEROIN
OR HUMAN ON THE SIDEWALK AND
THOSE ARE EVERYWHERE BUT THAT IS
TOTALLY COOL.
HUMAN EXPRESSION.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER HOME TELL
SHAMPOO BOTTLES.
A GROUP OF LAWMAKERS WANT TO BAN
THOSE COMPLETELY AND ANYONE WHO
BREAKS THE LAW IT COULD BE $500
FOR ANY OFFENSE.
TAMMY BRUCE, SHE IS A RADIO SHOW
HOST AND PRESIDENT OF THE
INDEPENDENCE VOICE AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
DO YOU FEEL SAFER NOW?
>> I FEEL WEIRDLY SAFER THAT YOU
ARE IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
NEW YORK.
THIS IS A PROPOSED BILL AND IT
IS STUPID.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE, OF COURSE THEY
ARE SAYING IT'S A BOUT THE
PLASTIC OF THE OCEAN BUT HERE'S
THE TRUTH, A HEADLINE AND FORBES
LAST YEAR, FIVE ASIAN COUNTRIES
DUMPED MORE PLASTIC INTO OCEANS
THEN EVERYBODY ELSE COMBINED.
CHINA, INDONESIA, VIETNAM, THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT THE
PROBLEM.
CALIFORNIANS STRANGELY ENOUGH OR
NOT THE PROBLEMS YET THEY BADLY
STRAWS ON THE PLASTIC BAGS AND
NOW TO SEE LITTLE TINY SHAMPOO
BOTTLES THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE THEM
IN HOTELS OR IN ANY KIND OF
RENTAL OR THE RESORT BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO SAVE THE OCEAN.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS OF COURSE
IS THAT PEOPLE THINK THEY ARE
DOING SOMETHING TO HELP THE
PROBLEM AND THEY ARE NOT.
AS YOU MENTIONED IN CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN RELIEVE YOURSELF ON THE
STREET, YOU CAN SMOKE MARIJUANA
TO YOUR HEARTS CONTENT BUT GOD
HELP YOU SHOULD YOU HAVE ONE OF
THOSE BOTTLES OF LISTERINE.
THAT NOW IS THE PROBLEM.
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WITH THE ON THE STREET
AND WITH NOBODY BEING ABLE TO
SHAMPOO, IT WILL START SMELLING
PRETTY BAD IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A REASON
THEY CALL THE GOLDEN STATE
SADLY.
YOU ARE TOTALLY RIGHT AND I
DIDN'T CONNECT THE DOTS BECAUSE
I'M IN CALIFORNIA AND A LITTLE
HIGH FIVE BEING HONEST.
IT DOESN'T ASSAULT ON
CLEANLINESS.
SPEAK OF THE TINY BOTTLE
SUGGEST, THERE ARE DRUGS ALL THE
TIME AND WHEN YOU GET ME SHOWER
THE TINY BOTTLE SAYS TO YOU,
MAKE IT QUICK.
YOU HAVE ENOUGH FOR ME, A
QUARTER'S WORTH OF SHAMPOO.
DON'T LINGER IN THERE, THIS IS A
BRIEF VISIT.
THEY ARE SAYING SHOULD PUT IN
DISPENSERS LIKE A SPA FOR THEN
YOU WILL SPEND AN HOUR IN THE
SHOWER USING ALL THE WATER AND
THEN OF COURSE THAT WILL BE A
CRIME.
I'M WAITING --
>> Tucker: OF THE LAW OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
OR THEY MAY TOUCH MAKES IT
WORSE.
I WILL GO BUY A HUNDRED OF THOSE
LITTLE BOTTLES WHEN I LEAVE HERE
AND THAT IS ALL I WILL USE IN MY